ونبدا هذه التطورات العاجله من رفح حيث
ارتفع عدد الشهداء في قصف اسرائيلي على
منزلين غرب رفح جنوبي قطاع غزه الى 12
شهيدا وعشرات الجرحى بينهم اطفال وقد وصلت
جثامين الشهداء والجرحى الى مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى عن هذه الغاره وهذه المجزره ينضم
الينا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هاني الشاعر
هاني ماذا عن هذه الغاره وما خلفته وهل
هناك امكانيه ان يكون عدد من سقطوا في هذه
الغاره
اكبر نعم عبد القادر هذا واضح من ارتفاع
المتسارع في اعداد الشهداء بانه مرشح
للزياده في ظل تاكيد الدفاع المدني بانه
يبحث عن مفقودين اسفل ركام المنازل التي
قصفت قبل اقل من نصف ساعه من الان في
منطقه الحي السعودي وكذلك ايضا منطقه تل
السلطان عما عبد القادر بان هذ هذه
المناطق على وجه التحديد تعتبر اكثر مناطق
مدينه رفح اكتظاظا بالنازحين وهي المنطقه
التي قالت اسرائيل بانها منطقه امنه واقام
النازحين مئات الاف الخيام وكذلك اكتظ في
الطرقات وعلى الارصفه وفي داخل المنازل و
حتى على اسطح المنازل امتلات بالنازحين
وهذه الغارات تعني ان هناك سيناريوهات قد
تكوم في اسوئها ارتكاب لمجازر كبيره بحق
النازحين بفعل هذه الغارات المتزامنه وقبل
لحظات من الان وصلت معلومات اوليه عن غاره
جديده في منطقه تل السرطان لكن يجري
التحري والتاكد عن مكان ومايه هذه الغاره
التي طالت المنطقه الغربيه حتى اللحظه ما
تزال طواقم الاسعاف والدفاع المدني عبد
القادر تعمل في هذه المناطق الواقع غربي
رفح وهذا المشفى استقبل عشره من الشهداء
ومشفى الشهيد ابو يوسف النجار استقبل على
الاقل شهيدين وهناك يعني معلومات اوليه عن
وصول شهيد جديد قبل قليل عباره عن اشلا
الى جانب عشرات من المصابين جلهم كانوا من
الاطفال والنساء في مشاهد مؤلمه وقاسيه
وبكل تاكيد من بين هؤلاء النازحين نزحوا
من خارج مدينه رفح لدى اقربائهم داخل
المنازل التي كانت عرضه للغارات الجويه
الاسرائيليه حتى هذه اللحظه ما زلنا نستمع
ايضا لاصوات الطائرات الحربيه تحلق على
مستويات مختلفه هنا في مدينه رفح جنوبي
قطاع غزه وهذا ربما ينذر بمزيد من الغارات
الجويه على هذه ال مدينه التي ما تزال
تشهد تكثيفا للغارات الجويه منذ عده ايام
تطال منازل سكنيه تطال منطقه الحدود
المنطقه الشماليه عبد القادر من
مدينه امداد الشهداء حتى الان اثر هذه
الغاره ارتفاع عدد الشهداء اثر غارات
اسرائيليه على منزلين غرب مدينه رفح الى
14 شهيدا حتى الان هاني
تفضل
نعم عبد القادر هذا ما كنا نتحدث عنه قبل
قليل ان العدد مرشح للزياده وتوق من
الاسعاف ما تزال تعمل في المكان والدفاع
المدني وتاكيدا بان هناك مفقودين مازالوا
تحت ركام منزل عائله فحجان الواقع بالقرب
من مفترق ابو السعيد في حيت للسلطان
الغربي مدينه رفح هذه المنطقه كما اشرنا
سابقا ممتلئه تماما بالنازحين سواء كانوا
في خيام سواء كانوا في منازل على الارصفه
فربما الغاره الواحده توقع هذا الكم
الكبير من الشهداء والجرحى بفعل هذه
الغارات التي ستن نفذت عفوا في المنطقه
الغربيه وربما تنفذ مثيلها سيما انها كانت
متزامنه ويجري الحديث عن غارات اخرى في
هذه اللحظات في المنطقه الغربيه من مدينه
رفح بالعوده الى تطورات الاوضاع مساء امس
ايضا في مدينه رفع عبد القادر كان هناك
قصف منزل في مخيم لعوت غربي مدينه رفح
وادت هذه الغاره الى ارتقاء ثلاثه من
الفلسطينيين بينهم كبار سن سيدات واصابه
العشرات لان هذه الغاره كانت في منطقه
تعتبر مخيم للاجئين الفلسطينيين فضلا عن
ذلك قصف مركبه مدنيا في منطقه مخيم
الشابوره وقصف مدفعيا كان في المنطقه
الشرقيه لمدينه رفح واطلاق نار مكثف كان
بشكل ملحوظ وايضا لافت في المنطقه الغربيه
الساحليه لمدينه رفح علما ايضا بان
المنطقه الساحليه ممتلئه تماما بالنازحين
الذين نزحوا من مختلف مناطق قطاع غزه الى
هذه المنطقه للاحتماء
من نيران الحرب الاسرائيليه بناء على
الطلب الاسرائيلي بالتوجه الى هذه المنطقه
لكن عندما وصلوا فوجئوا بالقصف الاسرائيل
وكذلك اطلاق النار والتضييق من قبل القوات
البحريه الاسرائيليه وتار ايضا من القوات
الجويه التي تنفذ غاراتها على هذه المنطقه
الواقعه غربي مدينه رفح هناك ايضا تخوفات
كبيره لدى السكان عبد القادر حقيقه هنا في
رفح من ان هذه الغارات قد تكون مقدمه
لتنفيذ عمل بري على قطاع غزه سيما انها
تاتي تاتي متزامنه مع تلويحات اسرائيليه
حول امكانيه توسع العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه على مدينه رفح هنا جنوبي قطع
غز المنطقه التي تعتبر الاعلى نسبيا على
مستوى القطاع من حيث اعداد النازحين الذين
نزحوا من مختلف في مناطق قطاع غزه الى هذه
المدينه الضيقه الصغيره وسط تردي الاوضاع
الانسانيه وسط اجواء بارده ماطره افتقار
الادنى مقاومات الحياه بالنسبه لهؤلاء
النازحين في هذه المناطق الواقعه بالتحديد
في المناطق الغربيه والغربيه الجنوبيه
وكذلك المنطقه الساحليه هذه الاحداث
واللافت منها ايضا عبد القادر ان بعضا من
هذه الغارات طالت منطقه الحدود مع مصر حيث
سجل في الساعات الماضيه او على الاقل خلال
ال 24 ساعه الماضيه تسع غارات جويه
اسرائيليه طالت منطقه يبنا منطقه بوابه
صلاح الدين منطقه البرازيل البعض من هذه
الغارات كان في مناطق مجاوره تماما لمناطق
اقامه النازحين بالتالي ادت هذه الغارات
الى استشهاد فلسطيني على الاقل واصابه
اخرين ويجري الحديث عن فقدان اخرين في
احدى الغارات في منطقه حي البرازيل الواقع
الجنوبي شرقي مدينه رفح منذ خمسه ايام رفح
تاخذ الاوضاع بداخلها هنا منحا تصاعديا
سواء على صعيد حده وكثافه الغارات الجويه
التي تقوم بها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
عدا ذلك تسمع اصوات الاشتباكات واصوات
القصف في المناطق الجنوبيه لخان يونس
والمناطق الغربيه طوال ساعه النهار نسمع
بشكل واضح اصوات نسف المنازل واطلاق النار
والقذائف كذلك طائرات مروحيه كانت تحلق في
الجزء الغربي الشمالي من مدينه رفح كانت
تطلق بعض الصواريخ سوب مدينه خان يونس
جنوب قطاع غزه هذه المدينه التي ما تزال
عبد القادر تشهد عمليه عسكريه خاصه في
المنطقه الوسطى والمنطقه الغربيه وارتفاع
هناك في اعداد الشهداء حيث وصل على الاقل
سبعه من الشهداء الى مجمع ناصر الطبي كذلك
المشفى الاوروبي جراء غارات سواء من طارات
مص يد ان اذكر معك باهم ما ذكرته قبل قل
فيعلق هذذه الغاره ونحن نشاهد صورها او
كنا نشاهد صورها الان سواء الذين وصلوا
الى المستشفى نساء
واطفال ضحايا هذه الغاره وذكرت ايضا
معلومه مهمه طبعا رفح كلها مقتضى بالسكان
ولكن هذه المنطقه المستهدفه تحديدا ربما
تكون من بين اشد الاماكن اكتظاظا بالسكان
هاني كما ذكرت اليس
كذلك هذا صحيح عبد القادر يعني منذ بدء
الحرب على قطع غزه جرى تحديد منطقه تل
السلطان تحديدا والحي السعودي ومنطقه
المواصي في رفح على انها مناطق امنه
بالتالي بدا الزحف والنزوح اليها من شمالي
قطع غزه ومن ثم من مدينه غزه واخر عمليات
النزوح كانت من مدينه خانيونس المجاوره
التي ما تزال تشهد عمليه عسكريه متصاعده
متواصله تتسع شيئا فشيئا حتى ان ساعات
مساء امس وصلت او وصلت مئات العائلات
الفلسطينيه من مدارس النازحين في خان يونس
الى مدينه رفح بعد ما اقتحمت القوات
الاسرائيليه مدارس مصطفى حافظ وزهره وايضا
حياه وهي تقع في الجزء الشرقي من مجمع
ناصر الطبي وقامت باحتجاز مئات
الفلسطينيين ومن ثم اطلقت سراحهم واجبرت
على السير على الاقدام مسافه 10 كيلومترات
على الاقل توجها الى مدينه رفح الان هم
بلا ماوى فما بالكم بمن هم في داخل خيام
بالاساس مهترئه وبسيط وضعيفه البنى
التحتيه حتى والمقومات عندما وصلوا الى
هذه المدينه عانوا الامرين حتى في الحصول
على مكان للجلوس فيه بفعل الاكتظاظ الشديد
في هذه المناطق تحديدا ونحن نتحدث عن
الجزء الاكبر من هؤلاء النازحين هو في
المنطقه الغربيه من مدينه رفح وهذه
الغارات تعني بشكل واضح بان ربما الهدف
منها هو ايقاع اكبر كم من الضحايه سواء من
الاطفال او من النساء لان الغارات كما
تشاهد عبد القادر ورايت بان معظم من وصلوا
الى المشفى هنا هم من الاطفال والنساء لان
الغارات بالعاده تطال هذه المنازل وبطبعه
الحال من ينام في هذه المنازل ويظ في هذه
الساعه تحديدا هي عائلات فلسطينيه باكملها
وبالتالي اختيار ربما التوقيت ايضا فيما
تعلق بهذه الغارات هو ايقاع اكبر عدد من
الضحايا في صفوف المدنيين وكذلك بث الرعب
والخوف حتى في صفوف جيران هذه المنازل
المتلاصقه المتراصه في الحي الغربي من
مدينه رفح بي قطاع غزه نحن بكل تاكيد امام
اوقات عصمه جدا امام اوقات حرجه من عمر
هذه الحرب التي تدخل يومها السادس
والعشرين بعد المئه وهو الشهر الخامس وبكل
تاكيد عبد القادر يعني الامنيات هنا في
رفح ان لا تتسع العمليه العسكريه ولا
تستمر اعداد الضحايا في السقوط والارتفاع
بفعل هذه الغارات